well what about so when you were asked
to do you know i had uh dr drew on the
show and he was on master yeah and he
was awesome and he said it was amazing
and he said it was scared shitless and
were you were you was that i bet you
rejected it at first like no no thanks
no i jumped all over it um because
i hit show well i saw i remember years
ago
seeing ryan reynolds this youtube video
of ryan reynolds in a unicorn costume
i think it was the korean version of it
that's where it came from
and and i was like
i want to do that that just looks fun
like to know
nobody knows who you are and you just go
up there and [ __ ] off so you asked them
did your
representation ask they asked if i would
be interested and i was like
yes please yes i'd love to
count me in okay so how does it work
they make you sign a whole bunch of
papers i know the
drill you can't say a [ __ ] you can't
talk to your wife you can't talk to
anybody whatever
and so my wife knew okay my manager knew
my publicist knew
and my band didn't know my parents
didn't know my kids didn't know
everybody that knew had to sign nda's of
course and um
and i was in la working on a record
or writing or doing meetings um
and uh you know it's all pre-taped so we
shot it off
and it starts airing and
my kids are like
man this guy on the show sounds like you
i'm like
well that's crazy and i would listen to
it and be like
uh kind of a little bit and so we had to
keep like kind of lying to them and then
they'd see clues and they're like
there was this like meditation bowl in
one of the clues and they're like we
have that bowl that's got to be you
i'm like i'm here obviously it can't be
me
and they you sold it you sold that i
sold it man i had to sell it to fans too
because i we were
out on the road when it started airing
and they were bringing me like
rottweiler
like gifts and [ __ ] i'm like what is
this what everybody keeps talking about
what did you say what was the first song
what's the song you said
what's the song you sang uh the first
one was man-eater
wow no not the nelly frittata one but
the
whole notes the nelly frittata sing
shena manny
i don't know that one it's actually a
pretty decent song but so you sing hall
of notes
i love some holland did you rage it did
you get to pick the song
yeah i got to pick them all um it was uh
we went into halftime on the chorus it
was all like damn it
you know it was cool but um then we we
did
uh grenade bruno mars um
castle on the hill from uh
from ed sheeran did a live from sia
that was my last one you thought you
were gonna win of course right
i was hoping you know it's it's i'm
obviously not good at contests
always what did you get the first time
fourth i came in second this time so
it's
you're getting up there you're going
straight up you just wanted it i mean
that's awesome and by the way it was fun
man and and
it was terrifying because you're in this
costume
and you can't see [ __ ] you're looking
through this little screen
of fabric and they're like
no the camera's that way turn turn over
here and i'm like murmur
you and know singing live in this
in this freaking hot costume and you
can't breathe
are you mic'd inside no and i thought
that would just have been
so much better so does it still sound
good could you still hear it pretty well
through that mask
yeah i mean i guess they they got what
they needed um
they they said everything was good and
i'm sure they did some mixing and making
it
sound a little better but um i think the
year before was um
who won uh t-pain and they said his
costume was just like
you couldn't hear [ __ ] were you just
sweating balls in there did you just
have bree balls
dude i lost so much water
in every performance like i was i was
drenched
after everyone it smelled like an old
locker room